80 milliards de centimes ou ce qui
m'intéresse c'est lui et je vais vite
savoir qui s'est plu à jean si on est
milliardaire donc à rejouer c'est quoi
ce truc
non j'ai pas pu me payer cash un truc en
tissu à 199 euros
à mon avis il ay fè putois
je crois vous rendez pas compte de la
merde vrai coup de maître puisque je te
dis que c'est pas moi pas besoin de six
ans en fait tu veux tout garder pour toi
et 6 buts ou sortir de la merde désolé
de ce qui arrive je n'ai rien fait pour
qu'il en soit ainsi j'espère que cette
petite somme vous aidera à supporter
tout cela le vrai gagnant
toi tu as quelque chose à venir la
situation a changé
j'ai été licencié ça arrive à tout le
monde sauf aux fonctionnaires y'a pas
que toi moi aussi je suis dans la merde